we just keep moving keep moving you you
you obviously enjoying yourself
I'm having I'm having a good time for a
super successful guy you seem completely
balanced today yeah there are there are
things that you just cannot get away
from that you you know you hide right
behind but in for the most part I did
some smart stuff moving off my whole
family lives with me so I had to worry
about you know my father a mom lived
with me oh that's great yeah and I was
adopted seven months so you know my mom
and my mom near my biological mom you
know our crafting our relationship now
in the in the latter stages of her life
so you know that's you know but I didn't
want but I didn't want no [ __ ]
outside of that you know where someone
is is is sitting somewhere watching me
from a distance like you know that you
know some mom comes in day and they've
been divorced for almost 30 years was
crazy why maybe they live in the same
same under the same roof is hilarious
there's a whole nother show Wow and he
still dates you know say he's still
getting in and then she'll float over to
his side of the house be like see the
girl hey you know how are you know
getting some other I just want to get
something to refrigerator some spoiled
stuff that's kind of intense and then
you hear that on my door I miss my papa
could you tell her not to come on myself
yeah I'm like my parents you know so but
it's certain things that I but you got
to figure out your happiness and the
only way you figure out your happiness
you got to try to see or foresee what's
gonna be the problem so I get my family
close to me so whatever problem we got
to work out we work that [ __ ] out right
here get my mom and my my and my sisters
and my daughters close to me so they see
daddy going to work like this still some
work [ __ ] it's like none we just not on
the red car it's not just red carpet
every day
you know I got to get up I got to go you
know I got a talk [ __ ] I got a kiss a
little ass here I got a I got to do a
whole lot of [ __ ] in order to keep this
thing going so you try to you know in
life you try to see what try to foresee
what's gonna happen it's still gonna be
something always gonna be something and
just out
but uh you try to get a get in front of
it that's an interesting way to handle
it though to bring everybody close to
you bring your whole family in your
house yeah and not everybody can do that
you know because you know it's like you
know me growing up as an only child I
like having people around I can't be by
myself that's why I always would throw
parties I would kidnap people because I
just wanted people right now having my
family around you got do but like I said
not everybody can do it because it you
know it is interesting like my father
who has a great story my stepfather
that's a great story
you know he was on drugs or I had a
situation about with drug bout with
crack he ended up going to jail I wrote
him one letter I said you get out you
know I saved you life because I didn't
like writing letters to people and like
going visiting people in jail he gets
out this is around just before 9/11 and
my stepfather was incredible in my life
because he taught me how to play tennis
so back in the 70s and then in the 80s
he was like playing tennis I was like
wow I never seen a black dude play
tennis because you gotta learn something
today so yeah so people like Yannick
Noah in Le Nastase beyond Borg Vitas
Gerulaitis those were like heroes of
mine so he taught me how to play play
tennis so when he gets out he gets out
of jail and make sure everything is cool
I take him to the US Open and so there
he is made my pops watching Venus play
he's crying yeah this you know this is
this is how we got to live this is what
this is what we need to do so he watches
Venus play in a couple days after that
it was 911 but you know he stayed with
me he's been with me since then you know
early on I would just go by I check the
drawers make sure there's no
paraphernalia you know wrong [ __ ] smokey
we cool right don't do no more than that
and we've been cool since then you know
and it saved a lot of money in rehab
Young's and so I'm just right there
hands-on but sometimes he was just being
surrounded by loved ones is enough to
keep them from doing anything stupid
yeah it can and it was but it was bumpy
at first wasn't going to it cuz he wrote
a little book and talked about it it was
bumpy at first because when he first got
out I did some [ __ ] for him got him in
Scott him got him car whatever he
relapses
are gone he's back in you know so it was
a couple little things that we had to
work out but now no to see him now like
you know you know like you know we go to
these different events or whatever like
that he's his whole wall he old school
you know he'll do this the you know
there he got the actual photos you go go
bail up the film I got me a little film
Dabangg so he put the film in to develop
the film scene they put the feeling he
got a whole wall and everybody these met
you know all of his heroes and so like I
said you know I try to try to look try
to be ahead of the curve when it comes
to [ __ ] up [ __ ]
what about like what your creative time
when you have so many people living with
you and did you get do you ever feel
like boxed in no that's you know like I
know the best way to create is to have
people around because I could try that
joke out on them and they don't know I'm
doing that joke you know try this idea
see how they respond cuz your family
gonna give you too real don't get mad
terrible yeah you made games and so you
always got it to me having people around
to tell you the truth you know like
everybody my family you know they tell
me it's true for Brazil mmm that's
sleepless I should've just stayed sleep
oh yeah so it's like you know having
that allows me to create and then I have
my own little space where I go okay let
me get this
now let me they responded to that and
now let me put this together over here
in a little space so you have like a
little sanctuary I got a little I got a
studio that I said I set up where I go
in there and do all that [ __ ] you know
but it helps